how do you know if you can trust someone
I don't know if I can trust someone
well
I don't know a trick to it I do not know
a trick to it but I do come in
as I believe you do with high Trust
I come in with a um I'm told
sometimes I think I'm I'm told that I
trust too much sometimes have you been
hurt have you been betrayed
um and if you have has that hurt your
willingness to trust
no it hurt and I put that person and
those people in another category back
here and do my best not to let them know
that it bothered me at all but I know
when I'm with those people but a new
person you're still alone no I'm not
going to do that I think that's that's
the beginning of cynicism which I think
is a horrible disease of getting older
I'm not going to do that you're fighting
cynicism off as much as you can okay no
way no way no way and there's no there's
no there's no residual in it yeah the no
win yeah um it's easy it's clever
gets the laugh at the party
but uh and and if it sleeps well
it shouldn't be